[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france24 por
unanimidad la suprema corte de justicia
de méxico declaró inconstitucional la
penalización del aborto la decisión
sienta un precedente histórico en la
lucha por los derechos sexuales de
américa latina'
este fallo inválido el artículo 196 del
código penal del estado de coahuila que
imponía entre 1 y 3 años de cárcel a las
mujeres que abortaron voluntariamente y
a las personas que los ayudaran en estos
procedimientos aunque la orden llegó de
una revisión local tiene aplicabilidad
obligatoria para todos los jueces del
país qué implicaciones tiene la decisión
y porque el cuerpo de la mujer sigue
siendo objeto de legislación haremos el
análisis
además la corte suprema- también declaró
inconstitucional que las legislaciones
locales reconozcan la vida humana desde
la concepción reversando así las
acciones de cerca de 20 estados que
hicieron reformas en ese sentido creando
un ambiente de persecución en torno a la
interrupción del embarazo hoy el aborto
está despenalizado en 4 de los 32
estados del país ciudad de méxico oaxaca
hidalgo y veracruz y a la lista se
añadirá ahora coahuila
un histórico avance para los derechos
sexuales y reproductivos en méxico tras
dos días de debates la corte suprema de
justicia declaró inconstitucional la
penalización del aborto a partir de
ahora no se podrá sin violar el criterio
de la corte y la constitución procesar a
mujer alguna que aborte en los supuestos
que ha considerado válido este tribunal
constitucional y veremos el fallo anula
por unanimidad varias disposiciones de
una ley del estado de coahuila al norte
del país que había convertido el aborto
en un acto criminal la decisión no sólo
revierte la ley sino que también sienta
un precedente obligatorio para todos los
jueces del país pero vamos a agradecer
porque vamos a salvar ellos vidas y
vamos a tener políticas públicas que nos
permitan a las mujeres seguirá
atendiendo nos con seguridad ciertas
organizaciones defensoras de los
derechos humanos celebraron la decisión
y reconocieron que es un logro del
movimiento feminista mexicano uno de los
más grandes en américa latina'
celebramos la decisión de las y los
ministros de la suprema corte de
justicia de la nación de declarar
inconstitucional la penalización del
aborto en mexico este importante avance
de derechos humanos es también un logro
de diversos movimientos feministas
mujeres y personas gestantes sin embargo
frente al recinto de la corte varias
personas contrarias a la interrupción
del embarazo manifestaron su
inconformidad no es la solución el
aborto las soluciones ayudarlas
comprenderlas desde
para auxiliarlas mucho para llevar este
ese bebé que nazca en mexico el aborto
sólo está despenalizado en 4 de los 32
estados cuando grama que se podría
revertir de usar el precedente para
combatir por la vía judicial la
criminalización del aborto en otras
partes del país para el análisis la
conversaciones con maria antonieta
alcalde castro directora de ipas de
centroamérica y méxico y vocera de la
campaña mujeres vivas mujeres libres
maría antonieta de bienvenida a ellas
hoy
muchísimas gracias por la invitación la
corte suprema del país sorprendió a la
población al declarar que es
inconstitucional la penalización del
aborto aunque se basó en el caso de
coahuila cómo se materializará esta
decisión en todo el país qué cambios
traerá
la decisión es sumamente importante por
tres elementos el primero es claramente
responde al caso específico del estado
de coahuila donde hay una reforma al
código penal y está y el elemento
digamos el artículo que penaliza el
aborto es declarado inconstitucional
entonces se espera que el estado de
coahuila esa disposición queda sin sin
lugar y está de facto despenalizado el
aborto en en el estado de coahuila esto
también mandó un mensaje clarísimo al
resto de los estados que no han
despenalizado el aborto
diciendo que esa disposición en sus
códigos penales necesita ser removida de
tal manera que las mujeres puedan
ejercer su derecho y más allá como
ustedes planteaban en esta disposición
es de obliga es obligatoria para todo el
sistema judicial es decir que la que en
el momento que una mujer sea y pasé por
un proceso se acusada de
haberse practicado un aborto o que a
algún médico o alguna persona le haya
ayudado los jueces tienen la obligación
de dictar sentencia
considerando la disposiciones la ley es
decir a partir del martes ninguna mujer
debería ser procesada mi hijo
sentenciada a prisión en méxico por
haberse practicado un aborto ni ninguna
persona por haberla asistido siempre y
cuando este procedimiento sea voluntario
mariah la vida es importante es sagrada
pero en esta discusión del aborto hay
una contradicción por defender los
derechos de una vida que inicia muchas
veces a costa de limitar los derechos de
las mujeres se puede elegir realmente
una u otra como respetamos la vida de
todos
y la corte en este sentido es sumamente
clara en decir que ni en méxico ni en
ningún
ninguna disposición de derechos humanos
se entiende que la vida humana principia
necesariamente desde la concepción la
vida es un continuo la vida no empieza
en un momento sino es un continuo y
entonces el legalmente lo que dice lo
que dice la corte y ahí la no solamente
la resolución sino los planteamientos de
todos los ministros y las ministras fue
muy claro que en la protección digamos
al producto del embarazo
va avanzando conforme va avanzando el
embarazo pero no puede ir en detrimento
de los derechos de las mujeres entonces
en este sentido la corte pone digamos
claramente y de hecho el día de ayer la
corte hace otra otra toma otra decisión
en este caso en el caso hablando del
caso de sinaloa específicamente
diciendo que los congresos locales no
tienen potestad para
y cuando comienzan la vida y por tanto
los artículos que protegen la vida desde
la concepción poniendo limitantes al
derecho de las mujeres a decidir sobre
su cuerpo y sobre su maternidad son
inconstitucionales y me parece que en
este sentido también la corte y las
declaraciones de los ministros y las
ministras es muy clara de decir ninguna
mujer se embaraza en ejercicio de sus
derechos para pensar en abortar lo que
necesitamos además de asegurar que las
mujeres puedan decidir sobre interrumpir
o no un embarazo es asegurar que tengan
acceso a educación a los medios para
poder planear necesitamos reducir las
incidencias de de violencia sexual pero
al final si una mujer se ve ante un
embarazo no planeado no deseado y decide
terminar este embarazo es su derecho a
hacerlo precisamente por ahí quería como
de conversar con usted la discusión ni
siquiera tendría que estar centrada en
el aborto o en las llamadas pero estuvo
de posturas pro pro-vida sino en las
maternidades
en este tema de salud pública está en
educación para aprender a planificar a
usted lo dijo en oportunidades para
elegir cuándo y cómo maternal si es que
esa es la opción que elige la mujer
así es creo que hay un elemento central
en esta discusión que es primeramente el
reconocimiento del derecho de las
mujeres y reconocer la maternidad como
un aspecto voluntario o sea nadie
ninguna mujer debería ser forzada a
continuar con un embarazo que no quiere
o no puede continuar pero también hay
que generar como sociedad condiciones
para que esta maternidad sea deseada y
planeada y son precisamente los mismos
movimientos que hemos trabajado para
impulsar a la gente la agenda digamos de
el derecho a decidir de la interrupción
del embarazo somos nosotras quiénes
también trabajamos para asegurar que
haya educación sexual en las escuelas
desde las más tempranas edades que se
prevenga y se sancione la violencia
sexual que haya condiciones en los
trabajos en laborales para que las
mujeres no vean una limitante para su
desarrollo profesional en la maternidad
que haya acceso a métodos
anticonceptivos
incluyendo anticoncepción de emergencia
entonces el movimiento que ha impulsado
y que sigue impulsando la
despenalización del aborto es el mismo
que tiene esta visión integral de cómo
prevenimos que más mujeres tengan un
embarazo no planeado no deseado sabiendo
que siempre habrá circunstancias que
cambian de desafortunadamente violencia
sexual esto siempre habla a alguien que
necesita interrumpir un embarazo pero
sin duda la prevención es sumamente
importante y la suprema corte lo hace
claro en méjico y también de nueva
cuenta el movimiento que impulsa la
despenalización del aborto es también el
movimiento que impulsa todo aquello que
puede prevenir los embarazos no
planeados y no deseados mariah
finalmente por que abortan las mujeres
una ciudadana que es dueña de su
autonomía que tiene garantías de
derechos humanos que tiene conocimiento
de su cuerpo no se embaraza solamente
para después abortar la mujer que aborta
es entonces una mujer que fue vulnerada
por el estado y por su sociedad machista
y sin duda la necesidad
del aborto no habla de que hay una serie
de circunstancias y las mujeres que
decidimos interrumpir el embarazo lo
hacemos por una diversidad de
circunstancias pero también es una señal
de que como sociedad y como estado
estamos fallando en asegurarle
condiciones a las mujeres para la
termina para que la maternidad sea
deseada y planeada y esto es de nueva
cuenta condiciones como educación sexual
desde las primeras etapas de la
educación acceso a métodos
anticonceptivos
incluyendo anticoncepción de emergencia
y una verdadera programas de prevención
para la violencia sexual y programas que
hagan la maternidad y el desarrollo
profesional
enpa tablets no entonces sin duda los
embarazos no planeados no deseados
hablan que hay una falla como sociedad y
como una falla en el sistema pero
también
hay que reconocer el derecho a la
maternidad voluntaria ya la autonomía y
hay mujeres que posiblemente tuvieron
condiciones pero en algún momento estas
condiciones fallan y ante el kobe de
esto es claro no un embarazo que pudo
haber sido planeado o deseado en algún
momento se convierte en si tu pareja
fallece por ccoo bits y pierdes tu
trabajo si tus condiciones
cambian puede convertirse en un embarazo
no planeado en ese momento no las
mejores condiciones y las mujeres
deberíamos tener el derecho a decidir
cuándo y en qué circunstancias queremos
ser madres pues muchísimas gracias a
ustedes por su análisis y para la
conclusión de las maternidades deben ser
deseadas gracias por estar en ellas hoy
a nuestros televidentes sigan en
france24 nos vemos próximamente
[Música]